normally you're working behind the
scenes so nobody knows what's happening
so tell us the truth I will tell you the
truth
no everything is fine yeah it's my
birthday
um it's my second or third birthday here
in Zagreb I think the first time was in
2019 when we had a classical tournament
um it's always like mixed feelings to to
work on your birthday but actually like
I I will be treated very nice with uh
with some nice Blitz today so I'm really
really looking forward to that Leonard
my congratulations on your birthday
thank you you're turned in 35 today
you're still young but so experienced so
of course like how is it going for you
here in branchester and I was wondering
how many times actually you took part in
this event as a photographer as also
digital boards expert like I've been
connected with the grand Chester since
2015. uh I think the first year that
they started the grand chess tour I've
missed only one event in Norway 2015 but
I've been to every event ever since and
uh yeah it's like it's like an amazing
tour of uh of great players and so many
amazing memories
so just just sort of just photographers
in the world I mean
I mean for your pictures and let's say
what inspired you to become to take this
role because I know that you were you
were doing a lot of things in the Chess
World so how the inspiration came and
let's say what are your goals well I
mean I've always been like a technical
person so like in chess I started doing
digital boards uh that's something I
still do even like here at the Grand
Chester that's basically my main role
and uh and adding like the photography
that basically came very natural because
I had so much time on my hands operating
the dgt boards and I was still also
already at my computer so I can just
like edit photos while uh while
operating the boards and then where the
inspiration comes from yeah that comes
basically from from the games I guess I
like the the energy of the of the
tournaments I like when there's a lot of
when there's a big crowd when there's a
big Applause for the players
um and um yeah like when when you put
the players in very competitive setting
there's always something magical that
happens even either on the support or
off the board the fact that you're also
chess player of course a very decent one
I mean do you think it helps you
especially in this profession as a chess
photographer can we call actually it's
like a different profession in a way
because let's say people without any
knowledge of chess can they do the same
thing as you
um yeah they can and maybe even better
but uh but maybe they won't enjoy it as
much as I do because I can just like I'm
I'm here also as a spectator as a chest
fan so I can just like sit in the
audience watch your game for like for
some like this game I can watch the
entire Blitz game and then at some
moment I feel like hey things will
happen like in a long time or decisive
moments or I see a tactic that's coming
up and I'm like okay let's get my camera
ready for for the action and uh it's
just like so much fun to to combine your
hobby with with your profession that's
for sure thank you very even though I
don't think so grateful this is you and
they're actually Lenny I was also
wondering you have this chess Photoshop
website so where you have a collection
of your pictures and I thought maybe
it's time to make a book I mean 35 is a
decent age you know for this type of
ideas no maybe maybe a book will come at
some point but um I I have like a huge
collection of just photos like I don't
know like almost 60 000 photos now uh
but a lot of them are kind of rubbish
you know like some of them are very nice
but yeah like I made a collection of my
best photos and sometimes I have like
Photo exhibitions
um I think there might be one coming up
in Sevilla uh soon or something and um
and I had like two waters in the
Netherlands before and a book it's a
book is outdated yeah like it's it's
very old-fashioned medium you you open
it once and then you just put it back in
the shelf so it's so nice I feel like to
have the book no yeah yeah it is so but
there's there's no plans yet but uh but
I've ever I I like the stories around
photos and sometimes times a photo is
starting point for a great story and
maybe that is something that I should
invest in to uh to tell more the stories
behind the photo like like what actually
happened there yeah and also the game
you have many stories to tell them
especially as a person who is traveling
all around the world over these years
and basically covered all possible chess
events that's for sure but I know Lenny
that you have also many different ideas
and plans in the Chess World and now
you're also involved in broadcast like
tell us a bit about this well actually
like in I've this this month I've been
very inspired because of a couple of
events that were going on so we had like
this Global chess league in in Dubai and
I think they had some very good elements
uh basically they they showed that like
it was a team event that every player in
the team could be the the most important
player of the team right and and
tournament ended that way with only one
player in the team uh bringing the
Victory and that's that's a very cool
concept and I think we can we can do
more of these things and in terms of
broadcast
um yeah like we I was a video
broadcaster for the affordable
championships in in Astana and hopefully
we'll have some more tournaments and I
can develop some more of ideas to
actually broadcast chess games but at
the same time it's a very technical job
so like you have to make sure the
technical part is right and then you can
do the Creative thing and but it's an
ongoing thing and it keeps my mind a
little bit fresh to uh to to do
different things in chess yeah now that
you mentioned those about the pictures
and the stories behind them like okay
the last question over here for this
interview do you remember one specific
picture we became very popular and there
was a story behind
um well there's one photo that I like
it's a very painful photo it's from
singfield cup I believe 20 15 or 16. uh
it's a game between uh grishup and uh
and Carlson and Carlson has been
defending the whole whole game and we
had quite a Slow Time control like the
game was very long maybe like six hours
or something and uh there's like this
moment like finally like Magnus collabs
lost the game Richard won he stood up
left and Magnus was like at the board
sitting like this for
a minute just like overthinking his life
while the art beater wanted to collect
the score sheet and all kinds of other
things were going on but um yeah it's
kind of like captures the pain of a
chess player who invests so much time
and energy in a game and the final
result is just almost yeah just
support we'll know about it and you know
being the juice first a little bit as
well Lenny thanks a lot for this
interview all the best of luck for you
and all and everything you are doing and
once again congratulations on your
birthday thank you so much